500 يوم مرت على بدء الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا فكيف تغيرت وغيرت تفاصيلها
المشهده في العالم باسره بعد نحو شهر من
بدء الهجوم الروسي
ركزت القوات الروسيه عملياتها جنوبا شرقا
منسحبه من محيط كييف وجبهات الشمال الشرقي
سيطرت روسيا على مساحات واسعه في مقاطعه
لوغانسك ومعظم مقاطعه دونيتسك واجزاء
كبيره من مقاطعه ايزابيل
لاحقا تمكنت القوات الاوكرانيه من استعاده
السيطره على ما خسرته من مقاطعه
جزيره الافعى قباله سواحل اوديسا على
البحر الاسود وانسحبت القوات الروسيه من
مدينه خيرسون الى يمين ضفه نهر دنيبر
معركه مدينه باخمد شرقا المعركه
الماراثونيه بين الطرفين كانت الابرز في
ساحات القتال فقوات فاغنار هي من سيطرت
على المدينه وفي معاركها بدات ارهاصات
الخلاف بين قائد المجموعه والقياده
العسكريه الروسيه وما حدث لاحقا من تطورات
تصاعديه كادت ان تصل اثارها الى موسكو
القوات الاوكرانيه استهدفت في اكتوبر
العام الماضي جسر القرن الرابطه بين شبه
الجزيره والاراضي الروسيه واغرقت قبله
اضطر دموسكووفا لتبدا بعدها بسلسله ضربات
وهجمات بالمسيرات على مراكز ومواقع روسيه
مهمه ومثل مقر اسطول البحر الاسود وحتى
داخل الاراضي الروسيه لم يتاخر الدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا فبعد وقت قصير بدات
واشنطن ودول الاوروبيه بتسليح القوات
الاوكرانيه بالمدافع والدبابات والصواريخ
وصولا الى القنابل العقوديه ولاحقا قد
تدخل المقاتلات الامريكيه اف 16 غمار
المعركه ايضا عشرات مليارات الدولارات
دعمت بها اوكرانيا عبر حزم المساعدات
العسكريه وحدها الولايات المتحده انفقت
حتى الان اكثر من 46 مليار دولار اما
الاتحاد الاوروبي فاكثر من 13 مليار دولار
شهدت الحرب في بدايتها جولات تفاوض سرعان
ما توقفت وتمسك كل طرف بثوابت يشترطها
لعوده التفاوض موسكو تطلب اقرار وقبول
الجانب الاوكراني بما حدث من تغيرات على
ارض الواقع لجهه ما سيطرت عليه من مقاطعات
اضافه الى ضمانات تتعلق بعدم انضمام
اوكرانيا
فتصر على الانسحاب الروسي من اراضيها لكن
الطرفين وقعا بوساطه تركيه واشراف اممي
اتفاق نقل الحبوب صيفه عام 2022 كما جرت
بينهما عمليات تبادل اسرع اكثر من مره
ومع تقدم اوكرانيا بطلب رسمي للانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي اضافه الى مساحيها في
الانضمام الى النيتو توجهت روسيا لتعزيز
علاقتها الاستراتيجيه بالصين ودول اخرى
خارج الجغرافيا الاوكرانيه كان اول
تداعيات الحرب هو حاله النقص في كثير من
المواد الغذائيه التي تنتجها اوكرانيا وقف
ملايين الاشخاص في العالم وقتها على حافه
الجوع قبل توقيع اتفاق نقل الحبوب في
اسطنبول بتركيا فرض الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبيه حزم عقوبات على مصادر الطاقه
الروسيه على اثرها قطعت روسيا امدادات
غازها نحو القاره التي شهدت نقصا حادا في
عصب الاقتصاد لديها رافقه ارتفاع غير
مسبوق في الاسعار العقوبات الغربيه تمتدت
لتشمل النفط الروسيه المنقوله بحرا لكن
سرعان ما ردت موسكو بفرض اجراءات قالت
انها عقابيه تجاه الدول الغربيه وتحدث
المسؤولون الروس عن ايجاد اسواق بديله
لمواردهم لكن هذه التجاذبات اثرت على سوق
الطاقه العالمي التي تسهم روسيا بحصه
انتاج يوميه من النفط قدرها 10 ملايين
برميل كما قررت واشنطن مصادره اصول البنك
المركزي الروسي والتي تزيد على 300 مليار
دولار حول العالم كل هذا وحتى الان لا
يعرف على وجه الدقه متى وكيف ستنتهي هذه
الحرب